yeah so good afternoon and well thank
you for coming to this last
I hope you really learned a lot of new
things during those two days and you'll
find out something useful during this
talk as well my name is Gigi Montez
medallists Sigismund I guess in Polish
version I'm working in lavinia Vilnius
with a small team on language generation
and against it since it is the last talk
let's probably you know be less
technical and get a little bit more well
philosophical and you know what is data
by data with Python a jazz data why why
we use it why how we use data to
communicate some kind of a message and
how does that relate to the other mode
of of communicating messages through V
storytelling like a much much older
technology than the data science and
that's what I would kind of try to want
to underline this difference between
data-driven messaging and and story
driven messaging the conference started
with the keynote yesterday on ethics in
AI and what we see in in well when we
talk about it's mainly you know this big
data driven solutions which also shows
some some issues like bias this and that
and there is no need to repeat the all
the funny old a little bit sad instances
of all sorts of bias no matter how much
data you will push into you know machine
will vehicle to decide who to hit in the
in the unfortunate instance of a car
accident there is no way for the machine
for the vehicle to kind of have a purely
data-driven data-driven decision and
then I when we think about how we as
humans do that we tell the stories to
ourselves what if all sorts of
counterfactuals what if I will do this
this will happen this and that going to
be
what we do is not really the statistical
data driven decision it's more like
causal causal inference and and through
the language through narratives we are
building that that's our kind of
internal internal tool and data on the
other hand is gonna be profoundly well
done there is nothing really causal in
it nothing really you know telling me
why explaining me what happened so with
this in mind well then I started like
that it probably should have named my
talk like I don't know solving global
warming and bringing peace to earth but
so let's let's go a bit more into more
details about V how we are applying Y
again language is important to explain
what's happening a graph he has the data
we've language of the data graphs and
while we can look at it you know apply a
little bit of thinking and we can work
out the details here we see a time line
we see countries you know you see
different lines we see some aggregation
for the world and we can infer and if
it's not readable on the y-axis there's
a graham based protein consumption so
basically people are are eating more and
more meat per / worldwide but you know
we have to do this mental exercise to
arrive at this conclusion so what I'm
saying is that data through charts is
mental of course useful tool it allows
us to analyze it in all sorts of you
know slicing and dicing but it's
actually this sentence when we see it we
are much faster to process it to process
the meaning and can we you know do the
action do the decisions at the end of
the day it's decision making which is
important no application of data science
and building dashboards so imagine also
that the same data goes to
two Japanese agencies this yellowish
line yeah totally different trend so the
sentence to be generated is different
like something like Japan should
continue supporting cup doing this trend
of downwards downwards
consumption of animal proteins when we
talk about natural language generation
there are bows too to let's say very
broad domains or areas one is
conversation are conversational
interfaces and yesterday were was also
very good presentation by omit from
booking.com how how the applying
applying that in chat boxes for the chat
box of course not not only analogy but
you also have to understand the language
but that's one area and I'm not touching
it it's it's different let's say
different domain what interests me is
data to text so you have O's in a
simplest form CSV files and and you you
have to describe them so where you have
data from any sorts of sensors or
business environments and you want to
generate descriptions for that so it's
slightly different it's different from
conversational agents in that that you
have to be really precise in what are
you generating so kind of the textbook
text textbook example of natural
language generation is weather reports
yes so you have weather temperature wind
speed humidity and it generates reports
saying don't forget an umbrella so for
that of course you don't need the energy
technology but imagine you are a
operator Advan or region
your crews and your job is to prepare
the crew on the ship and the passengers
for that trip you have to provide data
and kind of a description for the
captain how to comply with regulations
maybe because if the wind speed or wave
height is bigger than something by the
regulation that and that everything has
to be tied to the ground for the
customers you need to generate
descriptions how to how to you know what
what kind of clothes to take and so on
for the engine operators how to optimize
fuel consumption so all of a sudden this
complex job of handling handling weather
concerns business concerns regulation
concerns turns into the grueling job of
writing a hundred reports for twenty
ports because we were are like many
stops along the way for the difference
for the different stakeholders in that
domain so and the date is always the
same yes so you don't want to kind of
repeatedly run and run the same the same
report with different different
parameters so even in the domains where
apparently very Ron no no no such a
broad scope for the natural language
generation it looks like okay you can
have a template or something even in
most cases we are quickly seeing that
some kind of automation is necessary yes
very where is the gap in the in all that
process again I as I was starting in the
end well we can replace business
intelligence basically any sort of data
analytics Jupiter notebooks whatnot yes
everywhere you have where you have to
communicate the message based on your on
your data so there is this gap that you
always show you know nice charts
nice nice lights but but very is no
again no call-to-action no description
of why this of that is important it's up
to the reader to infer that again and I
don't want to say that natural language
generation explains everything
where is about to know about to know
about this business domain but since we
have is gonna be story story consumers
is seeing some kind of a text
explanatory text in fact triggers faster
our discussions about this were thinking
again with causal causal inference
that's a screenshot from the meta base
business intelligence system open source
tool which is just kind of a nice a nice
nice set up again as in the previous
examples I was showing after examining
it a bit we can understand that it's
it's all about sales there is some kind
of you know upwards upwards dynamics and
sales what we don't really you know get
the message do I have to act on that
sales data or should I hold do I have to
call bill to clarify something there is
nothing nothing really in here when you
when we look only purely @v @v dashboard
and just before going forward I think
that's also the same for gain for the
other data science domains the adoption
rate the usage of all tools in business
is really low so companies invest like
gazillion of dollars in trying to bring
tools which explain show the data to the
business but then nobody is using them
why part of the reason is that we're at
different functions expected from the
from the BI tools so from IT marketing
to the
executive management so think about this
again this Norwegian ship with a lot of
a lot of different stakeholders inside
who need to consume the same data but
with different emphasis different
messages different things to do about it
and the same also different objectives
what do we need from that so again the
data is profoundly silent for all of
those different domains and texts can
can come to the rescue
where is actually the a finger is a
point in why all the fairy tales started
we start with this Once Upon a Time
because that kind of signals for us that
we are transitioning to different
different worlds but there is an energy
some kind of imagination and so on
so again when I'm adding some kind of
text to my my descriptions it sets us
you know on this path of thinking okay
what do I see here
so if I add to the same dashboard some
of the time series analysis it kind of
immediately you know I get the message
what's what's happening sail steadily
increased from 2017 to 2019 and during
2020 groves there stops it's a sample
data so that's why it's it's a bit into
the future but that's first couple of
sentences actually you know talk more
about important aspects in this data the
same goes for v4 the other other
dashboard for villa charts so yeah this
kind of enriches V what what data the
waste data talks to us so how do we do
that
most descriptions we building a open
source text generation platform
accelerate a text and from the very high
level oh it's electricity so from the
heart very high level it's kind of
splits and
- - molds from Vedic and of strategic
level we recognize that we cannot rely
on any data driven approaches we have to
have a small rules based approach which
sets what exactly needs to be told where
it has to be told and then at the
tactical level think about parts of the
sentence how sentence ends I joined when
we can we can learn from the data how to
do that so it's kind of a mixture or
form of rules and and and and more more
data-driven things and for those of you
who are following the you know the
arranging war on Twitter between between
connectionists and the guys who
defending a little bit of a structured
approach today I've is Gary Marcos and
and and then the rest of the deep deep
learning community that's a thing the
kind of similar thinking that we cannot
we cannot really have one bullet in
language a special language generation
kind of a which solves everything we
have to have this double approach of
rules-based and strategy and then at the
tactical level I call sentence
realization surface realization the data
thing of course
for example this there is a lot of scope
to even make it more simply pop
simplified and introduce more data data
analysis for example I truly believe
that if you know a conditional sentences
can be eliminated from this abstract
meaning representation we can learn we
can learn from data which branch to pick
based on on the inputs input
descriptions input description input
data from the from the business analysis
so but but still it will it still
remains as we as this kind of e
programming very high level
programming environment and for those of
you who saw the LEGO robots programming
think it's salsa and exactly the same
the same the same logic right so where
is all obviously this elephant in the
room here so far is that okay it's one
thing to to generate text but no
language generation system can actually
tell you what to generate what to tell
yes so there has to be some kind of a
some kind of data science component
inside so for example if I have a time
series which point in the time series is
worth describing so what we have here is
that in essence you are talking we are
talking about three three component
systems where you have some kind of
presentation layer Business Intelligence
Platform meta base power bi you name it
whatever you use then some kind of data
science tool which analyzes data and
extracts important points and then the
natural language generation system which
you know starts talking about that and
the open source is really shines in this
area and this you know ability to to mix
and match different technologies so
that's one of the motivations why we
chose to make accelerated text as the
open source project not-not-not closed
source so but that's kind of a very
important thing to always have in mind
because all we often when we when we
talk about natural language generation
you will get requests saying ok so as if
the system itself will know what's
important to communicate so that's this
is not the case you can have create the
document plan with this but import kind
of data importance and data points are
fed in from for the froofy data science
platform
just to of course everyone with an
interest in natural language generation
talked to transformers and that's the
results you usually get for the deep
learning system so for those of you who
didn't talk to transformers it's it's
trained on the massive massive amounts
of internet text with a huge huge like
language neural nets and yeah it's
sometimes it's funny so it's okay to
generates blabber II about fake ish news
but imagine if you want to feed feed
your business data business reports
something you you communicate to the
customers through v4 this system your
will gets well embarrassed at best and
at worst you will get a lawsuit so
that's why when we talk about data to
text we cannot really use you know
purely purely net neural Nets net
solutions that's why in the accelerated
text we approach this from this you know
perspective a Takei the precision is is
is a must we really really have to
follow each column in your data and
precisely reporting on it so that's the
kind of the key key key motivation not
to go full the kind of full speed with
the you're not neural net solutions yeah
so some of the applications have
applications where you can use it the
most obvious one is and the one we are
working now on his product descriptions
for e-commerce so if you have huge
retailers with hundreds of thousands of
items and you want to have concise
descriptions of dresses of shoes of you
name it you you want to have
natural language generation here also
what's important with natural language
generation and again as I was trying to
underline in the ship Norwegian shipping
example is that there are different
audiences for for reading the text so
when you're describing product for
e-commerce you want to describe it in
one way for the teenagers and in totally
different way well not totally different
but maybe using different vocabulary for
the family man
yeah device maintenance reports
that's probably skip to this one is also
interesting because you hear you guess
something is broken in V engine yes and
you want to have a less generated what's
which steps do you want to follow and
from what we talked with people who work
at factories usually it's not the case
that's bra you know professional
engineers who are supporting with
complex machinery it's usually just you
know well not really well trained
supervisors on the floor who really need
the descriptions of of what and how to
auto operate when when something is
breaking in the factory and again the
text cannot really be templated yes it
changes based on the expertise of the
engineer and only what kind of e what
kind of in breakage we are facing right
so once we have this running and og and
og systems
the benefits are quite quite huge
because in V environments were a lot of
reports were a lot of descriptions have
to be generated we can get this
consistent logic again which allows me
for better search ability better
readability of everything I have
then again analysts data scientists
don't have to write repeatedly the same
or slightly different reports which is
you know the distracting them from the
from the real work
what we haven't had another case is with
the in the banks with antimony
laundering the anti money laundering
data scientists would have to after
identifying kind of suspicious
transactions would have to write three
reports one for the customer one for the
internal bank consumption and one for
the regulator which is killing
productivity distracting again with
specialists from what we are supposed to
do analyzing transactions so again
having the nlg in the loop really speeds
up the the whole the whole you know
process of doing business right so
that's it's our one time almost okay any
questions thank you any questions
thanks very much for that the talk one
of the things that I just missed it
maybe at the start so but can you just
said your organization are deploying and
supporting these products I mean is
there something that your is that true
is it something that's already in
production or is it something that
you're working on as a hobby project oh
it's it's it's a production so we have
this you see the get her playing so this
is the open source product it still
needs kind of a bumping but yeah we we
worked on the especially B's Bank
example so we are deploying in energy
can be customized customized solutions
and we try now to make this platform for
everyone to have in the basic version so
that you can think or a bit with some
knowledge of syntax how grammars are
built was a bit of a training on V on V
vocab release you can you can start
start creating creating V and there are
more details with documentation and
everything is in that github so if you
are interested go here and then okay
yeah and which mainstream let's say
business intelligence platforms are you
currently able to integrate with
integration wise it's quite simple so
meta base is just something I picked
meta base because it's an open source
and it's in lisp closure we are using so
I just like it but then we'll also
employ a lot of Cabana elasticsearch
again you can you can push in some
something I'd say integration nowadays
is it's complex requires time but in a
way solved problem yes so whatever
clients have it's it's all let's say
doable and we watch this all works with
REST API so it's exposed that here and
you know it's a question of just
plugging it okay any question
no one wallets the end of the day so
okay thank you thank you for a talk
[Applause]